so what what city are you in tell me
give me some Road stories oh
you want some road head yeah give me
some road head all right first of all
man let me let me tell you something
about the road okay
you read that it says the only thing
tougher than a trucker
is a trucker's wife
that's hard as hell that's awesome
and the shirt says tough wife yeah it's
a pink truck and the license plate is
tough wife that's sick so is she also a
driver oh yeah
she trucks harder than her truck her
husband oh yeah
yeah that's like trucks yeah
you don't wanna you don't wanna you
don't want to truck off my wife dude
you do not want to truck off my wife
[__] I want that shirt that's sick
everyone in La buying vintage is just
trying to dress like
Midwestern and Southern gas station drip
that's all it is oh yeah you could flip
that shirt for a pretty penny yeah I'll
take this stuff 100 sell that [__] on
depop dude let's go to the middle of
ungralled guaranteed Melrose Trading
Post Yeah 100 bucks man
you're like hypebeast like fighting over
it dude that [__] is sick
yeah not as drippy
I got another one that was related to
the veterans and I put it on my story
and someone DM me said I know you're not
making fun of the veterans
and uh were you making fun of the
veterans
um
yes
no I wasn't it was just oh I know you
weren't doing that no hell no
not it was just a cool shirt bro I
didn't even you want a road story in San
Antonio I try to go to a gym
this was going to be my first day
working out on the road and I get an
Uber
literally almost die this is not some
hyperbolic Story I mean quite literally
almost died This Woman's car
was not mechanically sound and she had
no idea what she was doing on the road
she
she missed stop signs you know blast
green like chill at green lights just
doing the opposite of everything in
front of her this gym is supposed to be
seven minutes away
and she keeps missing every turn so the
time kept going up she somehow found her
way found herself driving away from the
gym and she realized three or five
minutes later that she was driving away
from the gym so she finally gets on the
freeway
she just no looked signaled almost
into a [__] trailer that's designed
to haul you know multiple cars yeah and
but we were like oh no I just kind of
embraced it I thought well this is it
stop number two I'm I'm going
uh and by the way people in Texas you
[__] cannot drive dude what do
they do they just all they all floor it
they don't look when they change lanes
they all want to die I think that's the
goal is they all want to go
so yeah she almost kills us
and then we finally get to this gym
and we're we're pulling up and I kind of
see this weird entrance and then I look
to my right
and I just see you know like Fort Wayne
or I don't know and I'm going what
let me pull it to the gate and it's a
dude in a military outfit
and I go uh
hey man I was trying to get to the gym
is it on base he's like yeah
is this an Uber
I say yeah
he puts his hand on the butt of the
rifle
and he starts inspecting into the Uber
and I'm going
you think if there's going to be a
[__] terrorist attack and he's gonna
be in San Antonio room okay
and then he goes well
she can't come in but you're good
and I say wait why
so bro I say so the gym is on base he
said yeah this is a military base
and I go yeah okay so there's a public
gym on a military no so then I say I say
is it open to the public
and he goes well she can't come
I say no dude is the gym on base open to
the public
and he said yeah you got an ID
I said what kind of ID he goes military
ID
I say no dude I'm a civilian I'm asking
if the gym is open to the public then he
goes no
this is a military base
then he turns to his pal in the booth
he's like this [__] guy
and I just I never felt so angry I'm
like I wanted to scream at him I said
listen Jarhead I'm not stupid I've been
asking you if it's open to the public
yeah I thought you were talking about
public military guys yeah I'm just like
oh my [__] military guys out in the
public the lady makes a U-turn wait wait
kind of kind of sick that he thought
that you were in the military well it's
my haircut dude like
this haircut I mean I feel like that
makes you look kind of like that means
you look like little badass you know
maybe yeah yeah the haircut might have
thrown him off you know this haircut
this haircut outside of Atlanta New York
Chicago and L.A
in the midwest everyone thinks I'm
military every airport I've been to in
the last year when I like walk up people
dude yes yes no way yes they step to the
side and they go oh sir please please
have my first class seat yeah they all
asked me like P just strangers they'll
ask me to be like your military right
yeah yeah no dude
I don't know why you gotta start you buy
some [__] fatigues dude I have some I
don't know why I haven't Stolen Valor
yet like it's so easy
it's so easy
that's for sure
you want to talk about badge bunnies bro
let me tell you about uh you know
military bunnies they are 48 year old
white men in the Midwest and the South
so the place is called Jimmy Brott as in
brought groceries
or you know brought a bag of chips okay
Jimmy brought fitness center if you look
this up on Google it's got 324 reviews
so I'm thinking this is a frequented
place when you go look at the pictures
it's just people working out but I
should have known something was off
because
uh well one if I just read the comments
it says retired military so military
gyms are all I have known
um
so that's on me I mean I bet you will be
a sick gem to work out at yeah no I bet
everyone in there is [__] yoked but
if you look this [__] up on Google Maps
you know unless the website
is like a military website uh
I didn't even base directory.com
I I didn't even click the website
uh Joint Base San Antonio yes okay so
yeah if I click this I I would have
gotten hints but
I don't know I
did I on on on the surface would you do
some intense research on the Jimmy Brock
fitness center no also for my Google
results the first picture that came up
if you swipe over like three images in
on your phone
the first one that came up for me is
this [__] Christmas tree with a bunch
of bears on it
okay and then a pool so I'm thinking oh
okay this is just kind of like a local
family-owned festive yeah like it's like
oh that's cute I mean this Jim looks
sick as hell yeah I mean that's what I
was more hyped about I mean you could
see why I would be so eager to go and
then if you go on the map you know if
you if you scroll around you'll see
little things giving it up like Army
Wellness Center okay you know and and
Main flagpole Fort Sam Houston but
there's no [__] marking on the actual
map
so whatever I'm not mad at the guy I was
just more I was more irritated because
he got irritated with me and I kept
asking him multiple times I'm like bro
is this [__] open to the public
yeah public military
[Laughter]
so whatever so we leave and then this
lady is fully just foot on the gas
driving forward looking backwards at me
asking so what do you want to do I'm
like well I think you should look at the
road
should we join the military but low-key
that seemed pretty cool bro
those guys were cool man we should join
the military
so then I had to ask her multiple times
please pull over so I can figure out
what to do and she kept going uh-huh and
then she just keep blowing stop signs
and
uh eventually I convinced her to pull I
mean this is one of those things where
at that point
I would I would write the day off in
terms of a workout oh yeah I just needed
to get the address to go back and I need
to figure it out just like it's God does
not want me to work out today yeah
someone's giving me a sign it's not
gonna work out yep I'm not gonna work
out and also it's not gonna work out
so you know let's let's just it's a wash
I mean dude I have to say this
this you know I thought this whole
experience was going to be a comedy tour
what the hell what was that
was some big ass bug just like died what
the [__]
it's just like all right I'll figure
that out later